Olá você já reparou como o universo dos
adoçantes parece uma montanha russa num
dia surge um novo adoante que promete
ser o melhor do momento mas no outro
aquele adocante que você usa anos vira
vilão e pode até prejudicar sua saúde e
aí a dúvida bate forte afinal qual
adante realmente seguro são tantas
opções e Tantas perguntas que fica
difícil escolher o melhor para nossa
saúde hoje eu quero compartilhar com
vocês duas opções de adoçantes naturais
Seguros que estão ganhando cada vez mais
espaço por seus benefícios à saúde e o
melhor de tudo até agora não foram
Associados a nenhum risco de saúde
quando usados com
moderação eu estou falando da alose e do
imo imo esses dois adoçantes são ótimas
alternativas ao açúcar sem aquele gosto
amargo ou retrogosto que muitos
adoçantes deixam além disso eles CONSEG
reproduzir quase que com perfeição a
textura e o sabor do açúcar branco nas
receitas por exemplo a allulose é muito
baixa em calorias e carboidratos Além
disso ela tem sido associada a
benefícios paraa saúde já o adoçante imo
é extraído da fibra da Mandioca e é uma
opção bem segura para diabéticos
trazendo ainda benefícios paraa saúde
intestinal pessoal eu sei que o ideal
seria nos acostumarmos ao sabor natural
dos alimentos e deixarmos os adoçantes
de lado muitas pessoas conseguem e não
sentem falta dos doces e isso é
excelente é ótimo mas vamos combinar que
em momentos sociais ou com a família
aquelas lembranças gostosas surgem E é
difícil existir não é a gente não
precisa ser totalmente radical nem
transformar alimentação em um campo de
batalha se o sabor doce é importante
para você não se prive totalmente de
esse prazer mas desfrute o com
consciência e moderação verifique se a
sua saúde permite esse consumo de doce
de vez em quando mantenha uma
alimentação equilibrada na parte do
tempo e evite alimentos industrializados
que muitas vezes estão carregados de
açúcares ocultos esses cuidados já fazem
uma grande diferença paraa sua saúde
Assim dá para aproveitar um pedaço de
bolo de vez em quando sem peso na
consciência e se você optar por usar
adoçantes eu vou te mostrar nesse vídeo
alguns que além de adoçar Podem trazer
benefícios paraa nossa saúde Então vamos
falar sobre esses adoçantes começando
pela alul que também é conhecida por um
nome um tanto diferente de Psicose a
lulos é um açúcar que ocorre
naturalmente em várias Fontes
alimentares como nos figos as passas e
até no charope de bordo mas ela também
pode ser produzida de forma mais
comercial geralmente a partir do Milho
para você ter uma ideia a lulos tem
cerca de 70% da doçura do açúcar comum
mas com uma quantidade de calorias muito
baixa e praticamente nenhum impacto nos
níveis de açúcar no sangue então não
aumenta a glicose sanguínea cerca de 70%
da lulos é absorvida no trato digestório
e eliminada pela urina em vez de ser
utilizada como energia e diferente de
muitos adoçantes artificiais ela não é
fermentada no intestino que é uma grande
vantagem pois evita aqueles desconfortos
como gases ou inchaço abdominal que
alguns adoçantes podem causar em termos
de benefício paraa saúde lulos pode
ajudar na perda de peso e na redução da
gordura corporal Já que é muito baixa em
calorias apenas cerca de 0,2 calorias
por Gama comparado a Açúcar comum que
tem cerca de 4 calorias por Gama a lose
também pode aumentar a produção de gele
p1 que é um hormônio que desempenha um
papel importante na regulação da glicose
e da saciedade isso faz dela uma opção
interessante para ajudar no controle do
Peso corporal e na prevenção de
obesidade porque vai regular o apetite e
a ingestão de energia outro grande
benefício da lulos é o seu baixo in
glicêmico O que significa que ela não
afeta os níveis de açúcar no sangue
podendo ser benéfica para pessoa pessoas
com diabetes ou aqueles que querem o
melhor controle da glicemia Além disso
pesquisas e modelos animais mostraram
que alul pode reduzir o acúmulo de
gordura no fígado ajudando a proteger
contra doenças hepáticas ao mesmo tempo
em que pode ajudar a reduzir o peso
corporal equilibrar os níveis de
colesterol e diminuir os
trigliceridos assim contribuindo paraa
melhora da Saúde hepática e tem mais a
tem mostrado grande potencial em
combater a inflamação crônica que está
por trás de várias doenças crônicas
doenças de duração longa como doenças
cardíacas câncer e diabetes estudos
sugerem que ela possui propriedades
antiinflamatórias e que interage com as
bactérias benéficas do nosso intestino
aliviando a inflamação intestinal e
também promovendo uma modulação saudável
da microbiota do microbioma intestinal
do conjunto de bactérias boas do nosso
intestino você conhec a lulos você já
usou deixa aqui nos comentários o
segundo adoçante que eu quero
compartilhar aqui com vocês é a isomalto
oligossacarídeo ou simplesmente imo como
é mais conhecido o que torna o imo
especial é que é baseado na fibra da
Mandioca rica em
hemicelulose também lignina e celulose o
que oferece uma poderosa ação prebiótica
Isso significa que favorece o
crescimento das bactérias benéficas do
intestino contribuindo para uma melhor
saúde intestinal como resultado o imo
promove a produção de ácidos grassos de
cadeia curta no intestino grosso o Colon
o que pode ter efeitos antiinflamatórios
e ajuda a proteger contra doenças
intestinais diferente dos adoçantes
polióis como xilitol maltitol sorbitol
eritritol o imo não causa fermentação no
intestino pois não contém carboidratos
fermentáveis também com conhecidos como
os
fodmaps isso faz do ío uma excelente
opção para pessoas que sofrem de super
crescimento bacter no intestino delgado
o famoso cibo que eu já abordei em
vários vídeos já que ele não agrava
sintomas como distensão abdominal não
causa gases e diarreia Além disso O ío é
uma ótima escolha para quem tem sino
intestino irritável que constantemente
também tem cibo associado pois ele não
causa o efeito osmótico que pode elevar
a Reia algo comum com outros adoçantes
outro grande benefício do imo é o seu
baixo in glicêmico O que significa que
ele pode ser utilizado por diabéticos já
que não provoca Picos de glicose ou de
insulina isso torna uma excelente
alternativa para pessoas com resistência
à insulina e diabetes e para completar o
imo é extremamente versátil na cozinha
ele é um dos adoçantes mais se assemelha
ao açúcar Especialmente quando combinado
com outros adoçantes naturais como é o
caso da estévia e a Matina Então essa
combinação resulta em uma doçura mais
agradável um poder caramelizando e uma
cor semelhante a do açúcar comum então
você vai encontrar no mercado versões do
imo combinadas com outros adoçantes pode
encontrar o imo misturado com tamaa ou
apenas com estévia ou até mesmo com os
três juntos imo estévia natural e tamaa
natural Às vezes o imo pode estar
descrito como fibra tatapioca
ou fibra da Mandioca então Fique atento
a esses termos no rótulo e por que que
essa combinação é tão interessante
porque ela se aproxima bastante do Sabor
do açúcar mas com o mínimo de gosto
residual amargo ou metálico que outros
adoçantes podem deixar então quando o ío
é combinado com a estévia e a tomatina
esses três ingredientes oferecem uma
doçura suave equilibrada muito
semelhante ao que nós encontramos no
açúcar comum a taumatina em particular é
um diferencial é extraída da fruta caten
que é originária da África e ela é
considerada a substância mais doce da
natureza cerca de 2000 vezes 2000 vezes
mais doce que o açúcar impressionante né
Mesmo sendo tão doce a tamaa é usada em
pequenas quantidades nessas misturas
ajudando a mascarar sabores amargos e
garantindo um Sabor Agradável
Além disso ela é segura pro consumo
inclusive para diabéticos e também
gestantes sem ter os efeitos negativos
conhecidos até agora a estve que muito
de vocês já conhec também é uma
excelente escolha natural e segura
também extraída de uma planta a esteve
tem um poder adoante cerca de 400 vezes
maior que o açúcar O que significa que
você precisa de uma quantidade mínima
para adar o seus alimentos é uma opção
confiável e sem riscos conhecidos até o
momento pessoal preciso fazer uma Alerta
importante você já sabe que os adoçantes
artificiais em vários estudos já
apontaram diversos riscos à saúde
incluindo efeitos negativos no cérebro
também alterações no metabolismo
alergias e até câncer por exemplo
adocantes como é o caso da sucralose
aspartame e a sacarina podem mexer com
apetite levando ao grande peso e
aumentando o risco de obesidade e
diabetes tipo do particularmente falando
do aspartame e do acesulfame k a
situação fica ainda mais preocupante
porque esses dois têm sido associados ao
câncer de mama talvez você se lembre de
que recentemente o aspartame foi
classificado como Possivelmente
cancerígeno pela Organização Mundial de
Saúde além disso a OMS também recomendou
a redução do uso de adoçantes em geral
por quê especialmente para controle de
peso devido ao risco maior de diabetes e
doenças cardiovasculares até o eritritol
que é uma docente mais natural e com
menos problemas comparado aos outros tem
sido alvo de debates e estudos recentes
saíram falando mal dele embora a ligação
dele com problemas de coagulação
derrames e ataques cardíacos ainda seja
bastante
controversa agora mesmo com os
benefícios desses dois adocantes
naturais da alose do Lio que são
realmente interessantes e até o momento
não apresentam estudos que falam mal
deles que indiquem risco é fundamental
falar sobre a importância da moderação
ao consumir esses adocantes
naturais entenda que quando consumimos
um adante nossas papilas gustativas
identificam algo doce como se fosse uma
substância rica em glicose ou
carboidrato isso faz uma reação no
organismo faz com que o cérebro envie um
sinal pro pâncreas produzir mais
insulina mas como não há glicose
Presente porque estamos consumindo um
produto sem calorias a insulina acaba
ficando na corrente sanguínea E com o
tempo e o uso excessivo isso pode levar
à Resistência à insulina e também
eventualmente ao diabete tipo do ou
mesmo pré-diabetes Esse fenômeno pode
ocorrer tanto com adoçantes artificiais
quanto com os naturais no caso dos
adoçantes artificiais o problema pode
ser ainda mais complicado pois eles
podem contribuir para algo que os
psicólogos chamam de distorção
cognitiva por exemplo ao trocar um
refrigerante comum por um diet você pode
pensar que como não está consumindo
açúcar pode consumir muito mais e isso é
preocupante porque você pode acabar
ingerindo uma quantidade muito grande de
adoçante ao longo do dia então lembre-se
mesmo os adoçantes naturais Tem um
limite como eu sempre digo tudo tem sua
Dose Certa então use os adocantes
naturais com moderação também o
equilíbrio é a chave para tudo é a chave
para aproveitar o melhor desses produtos
sem comprometer a nossa saúde a sua
saúde muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço e um beijo no seu coração
você é feira